[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen sonntagabend und
willkommen wintersport gibt es von
norbert lehmann junior familie gute und
schlechte nachrichten heute zur pandemie
incidents in deutschland erstmals über
500 virologen sehen omikron aber auch
als chance für das ende der pandemie
australian open ohne
weltranglisten-ersten tennis star novak
djokovic oder liegt im visum streit
endgültig und hat das land verlassen
und dreifach erfolg im zweierbob die
deutschen frauen triumphieren bei der em
in st moritz
es ist eine einschätzung die hoffnung
macht der virologe christian drosten ist
sich zitat komplett sicher dass wir
wieder so leben werden wie vor der
pandemie das sagte er dem tagesspiegel
am sonntag derzeit jedoch bereitet sich
omikron rasant aus christoph distel
berichtet
in hamburg wurde erst dann hochzeit
gefeiert mehr als 300 menschen sind
dabei nachbarn rufen die polizei und
noch während die beamten auf den
veranstalter einreden trudeln weitere
gäste ein ein fest wie gemacht für nikon
zwar rauscht die neue variante wohl mit
milden verläufen durchs land aber zu
viele ansteckungen auf einmal alarmieren
den gesundheitsminister und drohen in
deutschland sehr schwere wochen wir
haben eine im vergleich ältere
bevölkerung mit vielen chronisch kranken
in kombination mit der niedrigen
impfbereitschaft ist das brandgefährlich
tatsächlich stieg die inzidenz das
dritte mal in folge auf einen höchstwert
und liegt jetzt bei 5 115,7 binnen
tagesfrist kamen 52 1504 neuinfektionen
dazu der virologe christian drosten ist
sicher alle werden sich früher oder
später mit omikron anstecken worin aber
auch eine chance lege denn wir können
nicht auf dauer alle paar monate über
eine booster impfung den immunschutz der
ganzen bevölkerung erhalten das muss das
virus machen das virus muss sich
verbreiten aber eben auf basis eines in
der breiten bevölkerung verankerten
impfschutzes womit patienten und ärzte
in den kliniken trotzdem vor der
nächsten belastungsprobe stehen dürften
wir werden ohne zweifel wachsen bezahlen
haben sowohl auf die normalstation wie
auch auf den intensivstationen
ich bin aber verhalten optimistisch dass
wir gerade auf den intensivstationen die
maximalwerte der letzten welle nicht
erreichen werden da waren es anfang
dezember fast 5000 corona patienten im
moment sind es mit knapp 2900 deutlich
weniger
querdenker aber auch raichs bürger
machen offenbar vor schulen und kitas
mobil das geht aus einem schreiben des
bundesinnenministeriums hervor danach
hätten gegner der korona maßnahmen den
einzelnen fällen vor
bildungseinrichtungen demonstriert
außerdem hätten lehrkräfte und schulen
drohbriefe erhalten
auf der s bahn gab es wieder demos gegen
die korona maßnahmen im thüringischen
greiz zogen mehrere hundert menschen
ungehindert mit fackeln durch die
innenstadt an verschiedenen orten gingen
aber auch tausende gegen verschwörungs
ideologen und querdenker auf die straße
für prognosen zur entwicklung der
pandemie geht der blick oft nach israel
das land ist beim impfen schneller als
andere seit anfang januar gibt es die
vierte impfung für risikogruppen für
alle über 60 und für medizinisches
personal
gleichzeitig verbreitet sich omikron
immer schneller die sieben tage incident
ist auf mehr als 3.000 gestiegen michael
b warum berichtet schon bei der dritten
booster impfung war israel weltweit
vorreiter jetzt versucht sich das land
als erstes an der vierten dosis die
können die omikron welle im gegensatz
zur letzten zwar nicht brechen soll aber
vor allem ältere menschen mit
vorerkrankungen schützen
ich habe eine lungenkrankheit und komme
immer sobald es geht und mache was man
machen muss auch für die kinder und
enkelkinder mache ich immer sofort einen
termin aus damit sie herkommen
obwohl die zahl der täglich neu
infektionen nach einer dunkelziffer
studie um die 100000 liegt landeten
bisher nur wenige hundert patienten auf
den intensivstationen
bisher ist die zahl der schweren fälle
erstaunlich gering geblieben doch wegen
der extrem hohen infektionsraten durch
omikron könnte auch diese zahl bald um
das fünf bis zehnfache steigen sagen
experten schätzungen dann droht der
kollaps des gesundheitssystems der noch
tausende pflegekräfte und hunderte ärzte
sind erkrankt die quarantäne wurde daher
schon von zehn auf sieben tage
herabgesetzt symptomfreiheit
vorausgesetzt tatsächlich ist der
verlauf bei omikron meist leicht die
mediziner geben entwarnung
schon morgen kommen hunderte
pflegekräfte zurück in die hospitäler es
gibt schon ein problem und zwar ein
größeres aber wir sind nicht in panik
wir kontrollieren die situation
und noch eine gute nachricht für die
israelis so schnell die omikron welle
kam so schnell wird sie wohl auch vorbei
sein schon ende januar rechnen die
experten mit entspannung
in österreich soll die impfpflicht gegen
das corona virus wie geplant im februar
in kraft treten bundeskanzler hama
stellt am mittag in wien den
überarbeiteten gesetzentwurf vor ab
mitte märz soll der impfstatus dann auch
kontrolliert werden zum beispiel am
rande von verkehrskontrollen im
verweigern drohen strafen bis zu 3600
euro
der designierte cdu chef merz warnt
davor russland vom internationalen
banken zahlungssystem swift
auszuschließen es würde russland treffen
aber wir würden uns als starke
exportnation selbst erheblich schaden
sagte merz der dpa us präsident biden
hatte moskau mit dem ausschluss vom
weltweiten finanzsystem gedroht falls
russische truppen in die ukraine
einmarschierten
bei einem wahlkampfauftritt in arizona
hat der frühere us-präsident tram sein
nachfolger beiden und die demokratische
partei scharf angegriffen die regierung
sei unfähig und habe die usa
international blamiert zwar machte
beiden auch für den anstieg der
inflation der spritpreise und der korona
zahlen verantwortlich bei der rede vor
einigen tausend anhängern wiederholte
trump sei eine falsche behauptung man
habe ihn die wahl gestohlen
das hin und her hat ein ende nachdem ein
bundesgericht in melbourne den einspruch
novak djokovic gegen die annullierung
seines visums abgelehnt hat ist der
serbische tennis star aus australien
abgeschoben worden das war es also für
djokovic mit einer teilnahme an den
australian open britta hilpert mit der
ganzen geschichte
novak djokovic verlässt australien er
hatte im visum streit verloren es ist
ein bild das ein umfeld offensichtlich
gar nicht mag ich bin extrem enttäuscht
lässt joker wird schriftlich wissen aber
ich respektiere das gerichtsurteil
ungeimpfte und mit falschen angaben ist
er vor zehn tagen eingereist sein
superstar status sorgt für tage langes
hickhack um die ablehnung und wurde so
zur politischen affäre
demonstrationen in melbourne und im
heimatland serbien
medienrummel um den nationalhelden in
abschiebehaft und eine regierung die das
vorgehen gegen einen sportler zum
angriff auf sein heimatland stilisierte
duisburg medien dancing und hexenjagd
nennt es der serbische präsident mutig
gegen eine person gegen ein land denn an
novak wollen sie zeigen wie die
weltordnung funktioniert so ist geborgen
doch belgrad bleibt ruhig heute denn
manche serben sehen ihren helden
kritischer seit er zugab als infizierter
menschen kontakt gehabt zu haben
es gehe längst nicht mehr um tennis
meint david diese sache macht nowak nur
stärke juni datiert
es war seine entscheidung sich nicht
impfen zu lassen er muss die folgen
tragen
novak djokovic ist nun unterwegs nicht
in die heimat sondern wohl nach spanien
wie es heißt zum trainieren
einer der großen internationalen
modeschöpfer ist tot der italiener nino
cerruti starb im alter von 91 jahren die
route hatte früh die textilfabrik seines
vaters übernommen und sich schnell als
modedesigner einen namen gemacht sein
stil stand für eleganz hollywood-größen
gehörten zu seinen kunden
und jetzt kommt zu norbert und zum sport
und zum dreifach erfolg der deutschen
frauen bei der bob em in st moritz auf
der einzigen natureisbahn der welt
siegte im zweier bob das duo kim
kalkilia buckwitz vor marianna janka
kiera lipperheide und laura nolte die
pro reli wie die natureisbahn von sankt
moritz hatten kim ki und ihre
anschieberin dieser buckwitz im griff
mit bestzeit im zweiten durchgang zog
nur noch vorbei am bob von
olympiasiegerin maria maria man kann
auch nur sieben hundertstel zurück der
dritte deutsche schlitten mit pilotin
laura nolte der letzte weltcup vor
olympia gleichzeitig europameisterschaft
rückt die deutschen bobfahrerinnen in
die olympische favoritenrolle dagegen
bekam die überlegenheit von francesco
friedrich einen kleinen kratzer platz
zwei für den seriensieger und die erste
niederlage der saison im viererbob gegen
den schlitten aus lettland allerdings
verzichtete friedrich in sagt moritz auf
zwei mitglieder seiner olympia co er
bleibt ein heißer gold tipp für die
spiele
gleich zwei erfolge für julia taubitz
heute beim rodel-weltcup in oberhof im
einsitzer holt sie platz zwei und in der
deutschen mixed team staffel siegt sie
zusammen mit johannes ludwig toni eggert
und sascha benecken vor dem quartett aus
lettland und österreich im mixed
gesamtweltcup deutschland den führer
julia taubitz auch die nummer eins in
der einzel gesamtwertung
abschluss des biathlon weltcups in
ruhpolding bester deutscher in der
verfolgung erik lesser bis zum letzten
schießen sogar auf podestkurs dann aber
ein schießfehler am ende erreichte er
platz sechs
und skispringer karl geiger hat es beim
weltcup in zakopane wieder aufs podest
geschafft nach dem zweiten platz mit der
deutschen mannschaft gestern heute im
einzelwettbewerb erneut eine starke
leistung mit 134 eineinhalb und 135
eineinhalb meter nur einer war besser
als er der norweger marios lind vi in
der weltcup gesamtwertung bleibt karl
geiger zweiter
mussten noch lang und dem ersten
sonntagsspiel der fußball-bundesliga
trennten sich augsburg und frankfurt
schiedlich friedlich 1 1 danke schön und
wir werden noch einen blick aufs wetter
über den osten und südosten zieht morgen
regen in den bergen schnee dazu weht ein
starker nordwestwind sonst bleibt es bei
dichten wolken trocken zwei bis neun
grad
das heute schon mal gibt es um 21 45 mit
christian sievers und morgen steht hier
mit rhi serien